I don't know if you saw the
Whistleblower on news Nation who found
the 20 foot egg-shaped craft but this
has been a setup from the very beginning
remember you cannot have a whistleblower
on mainstream media propaganda it just
doesn't work if you're a true
whistleblower you'll be like Snowden and
you will be searching for Refuge
somewhere but when you're on the
mainstream platform this is what they're
spoon feeding the public this is what
they want you to believe and we're
eating it up I have been on this train
my whole life as a kid in elementary
school I was checking out books on
ghosts and aliens and I totally bought
into it I became a Christian at a young
age and then I went astray because the
church didn't have the answers on all
the Paranormal stuff that I was into and
I went down the road of Witchcraft and I
was looking for answers and ultimately
that road was hopeless and empty and I
came back to Christ but when Ancient
Aliens came out and was telling me that
Moses was led out of the Wilderness by a
beam of fire from a UFO that made sense
to me that Ezekiel Saw a wheel within a
wheel with eyes all around it that that
was actually UF
that made sense to me now my worldview
and the Bible were coming together but
it was all satanic propaganda fast
forward to December 2019 when we get an
official space force space force H right
around the time that there's this huge
covid relief legislation it's hard to
understand why it was in the covid-19
relief bill but one thing is really
clear lawmakers want to know more there
over 5,000 pages and in there it says we
want to know everything you know about
UFOs what in the world does UFOs have to
do with covid I don't know but we get a
space force and then there's a bill that
says we want to know everything you know
about UFOs then the military comes out
and says yes UFOs are real and we see
them every day every day for at least a
couple years hm what happened to all the
swamp gas and weather balloons that you
were saying when I was a kid then about
a year later another whistleblower comes
out and says we actually communicate
with these beings and well they're not
really alien we call them nhi nonhuman
intelligences non-human intelligence you
know nhi like we we like to say in our
our language why do you say nhi I don't
think we have all the data to say oh
they're coming from a certain location
maybe they're coming from a different
physical Dimension we know there's extra
Dimensions we're talking to
nonhuman intelligences tell me you're
talking to Demons without telling me
you're talking to Demons they say they
may be interdimensional beings then they
say hey we have all kinds of things
flying all over in the sky we don't know
what they are they're not our technology
or the foreign technology but don't
worry about it they're hard L how can
those two ideas go together you're
telling me we don't know what what the
hell these drones are that's right
that's crazy I mean that's crazy we have
no evidence at this time that the
reported drone sightings pose a national
security or a public safety threat or
have a foreign Nexus now the new thing
that just happened is now another
whistleblower came out and said we found
a craft and when I was carrying the
craft I began to get these emotional
feelings of joy and song and I felt God
within me and something came in and
possessed me and it's guiding me to this
day they are literally using Ault
terminology they're saying we can summon
these things summon this thing possessed
him we're talking to nonhuman
intelligences and you can control these
things through meditation listen guys
you got to think outside the box you got
to think outside of mainstream media why
do you believe in aliens because our
entire lives we've been bombarded with
media that's showing ET and Independence
Day and all these movies that talk about
aliens that's not what people are seeing
in the skies they're seeing glowing orbs
in the skies and now it goes from the
Sci-Fi world to on the news and of
course you believe the news right cuz
the news never lies the government never
lies the military never lies could this
be one major scop when I was a young
teen I thought I was on to something I
saw the alien autopsy on Fox I saw a
leak here and a leak there and
misinformation and I thought I was
tracking the truth and I wanted to know
the truth and I thought they were hiding
the truth this is the psychological
warfare that we're in they want you to
believe that the power is in your hands
they want you to believe in aliens
because there are aliens guess who they
are the Fallen Angels they've been all
around us all this time who came and
talked to Eve in the garden a talking
reptile who came from the heavens right
and he said eat this fruit and you will
be like God reaching Christ's
Consciousness evolving into another
plane this is the same New Age
philosophy that's not new it started in
the Garden of Eden but now now it's gone
public and mainstream Satan and his
demons have created a mythology about
themselves that they are actually
visitors from other worlds Not Angels
not Spiritual Beings but physical beings
that are traveling from millions of
light years away then pumping out all
this propaganda like Ancient Aliens to
make us believe that they're just our
space brothers and we need to embrace
them because they're higher evolved than
us they have all the answers right and
when there's first Contact and they
start doing signs and wonders and
miracles and Healing The Sick and
getting rid of climate change and
getting rid of pandemics and all these
things we are going to openly embrace
them but then guess what they're going
to tell us that an evil alien Invader is
coming to this earth and the only way we
can survive is to side with them in this
battle and Humanity will put aside all
their differences to come together with
demons and fighting against Christ and
All His angels this is prophetic this is
in the Bible check this verse out
Revelation 1613 and 14 says and I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs think
about what an alien looks like like a
frog right and it says for them are the
spirits of devils working miracles which
go forth into the kings of the earth and
the whole world to gather them to the
battle of the great day of God Almighty
these frog likee creatures are going to
the militaries of the world uniting them
together to fight against Christ is that
what we are seeing today do we see us
Congressional hearings with the military
there saying that we have communication
with non-human intelligences we have
communication with demons yes is there a
United Nations Within agenda to unite
all the militaries of the world for a
great battle do we have weapons pointed
towards the heavens with a space force
yes everything is being prepared the
stage is being set for this final
deception that is going to entrap
millions of Minds when they are faced
with something that they've never seen
in their entire life a supernatural
being that can do Miracles lying signs
and wonders which will deceive the
entire world and guess what Satan isn't
red with horns and a pitchfork he
masquerades as an angel of Light if you
think that Satan can only bring about
fear and pain and misery think again he
brings love and emotion and all these
things you talk to any new Ager and they
will say that since they've been
meditating this is the most peace
they've ever felt in their entire life I
could give you an ecstasy pill and you
will feel the greatest feeling you've
ever felt and it's not of God this is
satanic so listen what this guy says
when he obtains this craft more than one
that made its way to the ground on this
particular operation I start feeling
extremely emotional and the closer I get
the more the emotion starts to overwhelm
me I feel this intense hybrid of sadness
and happiness and beauty and song and I
began wondering what was wrong with me
as I came over this object for the pick
there was this overwhelming sense of
emotion is it your feeling no I felt
like something connected with me I felt
like something had tuned in to me and my
soul and was providing me some sense of
guidance on what to do and how profound
what I was doing was and it was so
overwhelming that I began to cry and I
got the load hooked up and I began
flying away once it was just me and that
object I felt like something was inside
of me I felt like I was possessed by the
most beautiful spirit I'd ever been
possessed by and was it loving it was
loving but there was a sense of sadness
at the same time had you ever had an
experience like this before no no it was
a very feminine energy I'll tell you
that I it felt like felt like the spirit
of God but not in any masculine sense
and it wasn't like a soul it was like a
frequency that I was connected with and
whatever that force was since that night
it has stayed with me and as crazy as it
sounds it's what's guiding me now and
it's what's providing protection for me
it's changed your life it's changed my
life the Bible says don't trust your
heart because it's deceitful above all
things and desperately wicked who can
know it and this guy's saying that he
picked up an alien craft and felt an
overwhelming sense of joy and love and
all these things that people are going
to fall for millions of even Christians
are going to fall for this because they
think the devil can only bring you pain
and sadness and misery but in reality he
can bring you these false feelings of
love and joy and peace just like in the
New Age world and this is going to be
the biggest deception in human history
this is Satan's final Opus so now
they're talking about that the military
knows that you can psychically summon
these things in August of 2024 Jake and
the skywatcher team conducted their own
operation with a psionic acid to see if
they could summon a UAP themselves look
right here look at this one going down
and this one going up Jake says a UAP
dog fight erupted in the sky above them
he believes the craft summoned by the
team was Waring with a rogue UAP piloted
by an unknown entity attempting to
intercept right away when the psionic
asset went into meditation he is
reporting that he is engaged and in fact
piloting a craft and is bringing it in
so he's actually
telepathically controlling alien
technology yes they're literally telling
you that they are summoning these things
that they are meditating and controlling
these things that they are bringing them
about through New Age practic is this is
nothing new this is not scientific this
is not physical these are not beings
from other worlds that are just
traveling and checking in on us they are
appearing when people begin to do new
age meditation this is summoning demonic
spirits and it's nothing new it's been
going on for thousands of years as
documented by the Bible remember who the
Egyptians and the Babylonians worshiped
beings from the stars the anunakis
syrius Isis Horus and it's just Satan in
a new disguise and the Bible says that
the dragon which is the devil is going
to deceive the entire world how do you
deceive every being on Earth including
atheists who don't even believe in
something Supernatural you pretend to be
a visitor from another world if you were
Satan and you wanted to deceive the
entire world how would you do it how
would you get Humanity to welcome you
and embrace you first of all you would
disguise yourself second of all you
would pretend to be a being of light and
love and a being that wants to help
earth right well if Christ is returning
to Earth to destroy the Earth with fire
and Satan knows this he has to convince
Humanity to come together and defend
Earth against this external threat and
how will he do that pretending to be
highly Advanced civilizations from
another world who have the technology to
help us in a battle against Christ and
how will he convince us that he is a
being of Light by this soft disclosure
this long process of the Frog and The
Kettle turning up the heat a little more
and a little more we have a space force
yes we've been seeing UFOs every day yes
we talk to non-human intelligences yes
we see things flying in the the sky and
yes we've obtained a craft but don't
worry because I felt the feeling of God
and love and joy and song this is a
deception do not fall for the dragon
schemes and I urge you to break open the
Bible look at Revelation and see what it
talks about and you will see that we are
living in that very day today the
answers to What's happening in this
crazy world are right there in the Bible
please open it up candid truth
[Music]